googles daten brille hat in den letzten
monaten immer wieder für aufsehen
gesorgt
die startup unternehmerin juliane
zielonka testet sie in berlin
sofort kommt sie mit passanten ins
gespräch die brille wird offiziell nur
in den usa und großbritannien verkauft
und kostet und 1200 euro
das sichtfeld extrem eingeschränkt es
wirkt störend am anfang auf seiner seite
ist total faszinierend dass das würde
jetzt selber sehe auch aufgenommen
werden kann
video meines lebens aufzeichne für dem
moment wieder akku zumindest reicht die
energieversorgung ist ein deutlicher
schwachpunkt der gugl brille ein
weiteres gravierendes problem der
datenschutz
denn die trägerin kann unbemerkt fotos
und videos von völlig fremden
aufzeichnen
in den usa ist der einsatz der brille
deshalb reguliert in restaurants kinos
und auf öffentlichen plätzen darf sie
nicht getragen werden
juliane zielonka hat in berlin
unterschiedliche erfahrungen gemacht
die jüngeren kennen ist die lächerlich
an die finde es faszinierend ein paar
sachen direkt ich will nicht gefilmt
werden kann auch sein dass man in
unschönen situationen einfach die nase
das müssen wirklich passiert egon
hofstetter ist juristin und expertin für
künstliche intelligenz die benutzung von
googles daten brille in deutschland
sieht sie äußerst kritisch derjenige
aufzeigen ohne dass ich damit
einverstanden bin der mine bild
aufzeichnet und dass sich damit
einverstanden dass womöglich ins
internet einstellen der macht sich
strafbar
nach 201 201a strafgesetzbuches
natürlich auch gegen das urheberrecht
aus hier gibt es ganz viele gesetzliche
vorschriften denen dieses gerät nicht
entspricht
tim kessler promoviert über den einfluss
der daten brille auf die gesellschaft
und er berät unternehmen die levels
einsetzen wollen
das fazit seiner studie die gesellschaft
ist im moment glaube ich noch nicht
richtig bereit für labels wie daten
brennen zum beispiel ich glaube sie
haben sehr situative nutzen aber noch
keinen nutzen wirklich für den alltag
alltagstauglich sind diese kleider mit
integrierten solarzellen auch noch nicht
aber bei ravels ist vieles denkbar ein
luftfilter als halskette ist eine idee
oder kleidung die auf blicke des
betrachters mit bewegung reagiert
smarte uhren sind heute schon realität
sie funktionieren in verbindung mit
einem smarten telefon und bieten
vielfältige funktionen
inzwischen haben alle großen
elektronikkonzerne smart watches im
programm zurück bei juliane zielonka in
berlin
sie trifft sich zweimal pro woche mit
ihrem personaltrainer immer dabei ihre
fitness trecker er zeichnet die
herzfrequenz auf misst die bewegungen
und berechnet verbrauchte kalorien per
smartphone app kann sie die daten
auswerten
sogar ihr schlaf wird überwacht
für mich ist es der motivator der arbeit
verbindung mit den menschlichen faktor
dazu führt dass ich mich besser
kennenlerne und dass ich auch mehr über
meinen eigenen körper herausfinden weil
ich sehe was ich für verhaltensmuster
hatte rückblickend und das kann ich dann
im jetzt ändern
für die zukunft fitness trecker bedienen
ein immer stärker werdendes bedürfnis
sich selbst zu vermessen und ständig zu
optimieren
ich schaue eben nun mal sehr gern auf
mich selbst und diese diese dinge die
sprechen eben diesen egoismus an und es
ist auch der trick dieser internet
giganten um uns zu veranlassen
dieses dinge an uns anzulegen damit wir
daten liefern denn unsere daten sind
eigentlich das worauf es ankommt und
woran die interessiert sind
levels sammeln daten zum nutzen ihrer
träger aber auch der unternehmen die
darauf zugriff haben
der datenschutz ist dabei oft kein thema